I guess I want to start out at the
beginning and ask you a little bit about
how you got involved with this movie how
did you first hear about it and what was
the initial audition process like yeah
that was more than four years ago I got
a call from the casting director Anya
buck and it was he asked me if I want to
come in to do a casting for Terrence
Malick's next movie and that was
basically I didn't have any more she
didn't give me any more information I
didn't have anything to prepare which I
personally enjoyed and yeah and then I
went there and they gave me one of the
letters of the original letters in
English and I sort of improvised with it
and that was it yeah three weeks later I
got the call that I'm cast so you were
cast without even meeting Terrence
Malick yes who was in the room with you
when you're reading those letters and
doing the improvisation and there was
Grant Hill and onion de Becque so it was
the the two of them and they sent the
tape to Terry and he just decided from
just from seeing the tape yeah so what
were your initial conversations with him
like when did you first talk to him and
what did he tell you about the movie um
it was he called me and so we had just
over this year in preparation we just
had like several phone calls also
because you know we were looking for
friends for quite a while for like
almost half a year so that also you know
that's that's how we discuss a lot of
things and then we just it was just
initially like from the beginning on a
very you know I just realized from the
beginning on his that that he's just not
you know he's focusing on diet and under
whole story and not only like he's not
really wanting me to be this in that
character and you have to be this in
that way he was more like asking me
about my life and we would just like
talk about the life and the world and
and all that and
and when it comes to the movie when it
comes to the film to the story the first
thing he did he was sent me a collection
of the original letters that the two
exchanged while France was in prison and
that those were actually they're very
beautiful I had to cry just reading them
and they were very important for the
preparation and then also later on even
during the shoot they continued to be
sort of like the voices behind you know
that you could sort of here or yeah and
that was that was mostly with Terry was
talking about the letters about the time
about France about my possible future
husband yeah no I know with some of his
other films terrence malick like for
example tree of life and and some of the
other films he's done since then you
know he didn't exactly have a script he
had these sort of documents that were
used enough for this movie was there a
script and what was it like when you
first got your hands on it there was a
script I got it like I think four or
five months before the shoot and it was
a quiet well you know you know like a
normal script
pretty much and it helped like it really
it was it during the shoot it was more
like a guideline but it was good to have
a Gina for preparation because I could
see oh I need to be able to share a
sheep I need to turn butter I need to so
i sort of drew out of this just like I
could to sense a certain okay just
there's gonna be a lot of physicality
there's gonna be a lot of improv is like
I sort of I don't know if I I just
imagined from seeing his films or I
don't know I just felt okay even though
there's a script there will be a lot of
improvisation so I felt like I really
want to want to like really get into the
atmosphere of of you know of a farm of a
farmer and so there was a lot of
preparation of that and yeah well and I
know I was watching a movie again
tonight I've seen it a few times and you
know I mean the whole thing is there's
so many you know things with like
extreme wide-angle lenses and stuff and
I mean does that approach that Malick
Asbury is always shooting with those
kind of wide lenses with the available
light
give you more freedom than you typically
have because I'm assuming you can kind
of go anywhere you want and it's gonna
be in the frame and it's gonna be in
focus yes absolutely I think that the
wide-angle helps his way of in his
process because as you say it just
allows you to do everything you don't
have you always in focus in a way you
can you know you have this huge space
but you can move around you can run also
that the camera is movable because York
is such a wonderful almost like a dancer
with the cameras or eels lake follows
you and so there's so there's this
wide-angle really also gives you gives
you just so much space that helps with
you know feeling free and and you'd
never have to land on a mark or
something that is just very liberating
well it's a really beautiful movie and I
really appreciate you coming out and
taking the time to talk with us about it